jojo was geht hier vor max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video heute habe
ich etwas ganz besonderes für euch wenn
ihr niemand geringes zu gast als meine
freundin lucy wie geht's dir ich bin so
geschwitzt braucht es 20 grad
die ganze mit luca gedreht heute die
ganze zeit mit luca geräten ich bin
ultra geschwister also entschuldigt wenn
ich ein bisschen sehr geil ich bin
gerade aber ja wir machen heute die
touch marie challenge mit meiner
freundin da meine freundin ein model ist
wir machen das folgendermaßen wir werden
gegenseitig fünf körperteile erwarten
und ich würde sagen legen wir los
lusti du führst mein finger und die
erwarte was du mir von dir zeigen einen
gut versteht spricht noch nicht so lange
deutsch gesagt das ist ja nicht so
schlimm ich habe gesagt wenn es ein ziel
ist hier so jetzt machen wir das ganze
anders rum würde sagen meine lady gibst
du mir mal ein finger von dir jetzt
erwarten wir einen körperteil von mir du
hältst die augen zu
kannst aufmachen ist es ein land eine
rolle wenn es das knie oder leute mein
knie ist doch noch ein bisschen hörte
zwei wochenenden okay das bedeutet das
war was garten kommt für mich 1 0 für
mich nie davon gehört dass jemand bei
der taktik
eine zunge eine kleine zucht schnee
später kaum etwas schönes von der
tierhandlung ok wird auf jeden fall
matthias neue produktpalette kann es auf
jeden fall lucie es neue produkte
präsentieren nein wirklich nicht
wirklich nicht ich verspreche
martina ist schon so eine süße gewiss
den teppich verschlossen kicker immer
nach hinten
die eine die eine oder keine für canales
frage ich liebe einen baum
diese partie das war ich dachte das war
hier so diese partie und stellte das
gewonnen lasst doch mal leichter nächste
challenge
krieg
für die haare nicht gemerkt dass ich
nicht wirklich gedacht ist voll ähnlich
an das heißt 45 zu viel für dich eben
angefangen
ich habe mich viel wald mal zusammen 10
415 und kaufen
500 wunder
so leute das jetzt das allerletzte mal
55 ist die große frage wird lucy gewinn
was du genug nein
habt ihr nun für die ehrlichkeit
gewinnst du heute hat mich nicht hängen
doch noch mal tanzen zum schluss
thatcher
was war dieses video das war glaube ich
ziemlich lustig auch für euch uns als
auch eine menge spaß macht es euch
gefallen hat lasst doch mal ein leica
schreibt was in die kommentare und
schaut definitiv auch bei luca vorbei
weil daten meine bekannte martina eine
yoga challenge mit ihm gemacht
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen beim
klatschen sagt ist